alors quoi de beau
[Musique]
essaie de glisser un petit peu voilà
très bien ouais il y a du progrès
[Musique]
hein il y a du progrès tu le sens ou non
là tu Jama fait de rel
non tu arrivriveras à mettre un dauphin
ça rentre pas les dauphins sur le
traînau ESS l'équipe alor quadb s'excuse
de l'incompétence de son cadreur en
reconnaissance animalière il est belge
de Belgique il n'a jamais vu de dauphins
suite à un sondage au sein de la
rédaction nous en avons convenu que ce
sont des ça rent pas les dauphins sur le
traînau
ESS oui voilà c'est bien
ridicule tu pouras je sais pas dans le
scénario on pourra dire que tu essayes
d'aider les dauphins à faire du Gl tu
vois non non c'est toujours
des c'est parfa très
bien
tu t'assois sur celui du milieu
ouis et tu prends les deux autes comme
si et tu fais le mec qui est fier
d'avoir bien
rangé ctaes deux copains les deux autres
voilà B écoute c'est pas
mal est-ce que vous pouvez nous faire le
Père Noël
oh est-ce que vous faites Mère Noël non
c'était ma seule question bonne journée
si vous voulez tenz la boule peut-être
ça va aider si vous
voulez ouais bonjour les enfants mal on
peut vous poser quelques questions non
ça marche bol de le faire je te fais
tous les ans est-ce qu'on pourrait avoir
une imitation du soir
même ah ouais il y a du niveau là ah
ouais pas mal combien d'années
là 10 ans 10 ans de Père Noël bah oui et
vous Madame Mère Noël non pas du tout
non oh oh
ok ah super bonjour bonjour on cherche
un père Noël oui ah comment ça j'ai pas
trouvé moi le Père Noël je le père
fouetard est dans le coin ou pas une
imitation du Père Noël boule au moins oh
qu c'est joli le Père Noël pourriez nous
imiter un peu le Père Noël quand même
pour voir oh oh oh oh
oh celui-là merci merci oh il arrive du
ciel pas mal mais vous êtes livreur
ouais mais j'ai pas le temps j'ai un
client ok vous faites le faire Noël de
temps en temps ou pas non mais vous
livrez quand même ah oui je livre quand
même Père Noël il livre aussi ou mais je
livre pour mes clients mais pas pour moi
mais Père Noël non plus il fait pas pour
lui vous faites quoi le 25 joyeux Noël
joyeux Noël auss merci bonne
journée on est à 12 minutes 30 d'images
mais oui mais c'est parfaitement nul
c'est ça qui est génial parce que ça
rime à rien